hasta el mediodía de hoy la tasa de
participación en la segunda vuelta de la
elección presidencial en francia se
elevaba a 26 4% según un informe del
ministerio del interior- un número
superior al de la primera vuelta cuando
a esta hora del domingo 10 de abril
cerca de 26 por ciento del electorado
había ejercido su derecho al voto la
tasa de participación no afecta el
resultado del proceso electoral es
digamos un medidor de la confianza de
los ciudadanos en la efectividad del
sistema democrático siempre es
interesante por supuesto conocerlo y
además es la única cifra que podemos
ofrecer debido a que es rige el silencio
electoral en el país y por supuesto en
las ondas de france24 particularmente
aquí en el distrito 19 de parís es muy
poblado hay una gran afluencia de
electores como pueden ver a mis espaldas
y todavía hay una larga fila en la
entrada de esta escuela primaria hemos
conversado con ellos algunos vienen de
hacer compras otros de hacer ejercicio
nos comentan que hay mucho en juego en
esta elección y es para ellos una cita
obligada en sentido general avanza sin
incidentes esta jornada electoral quien
estará a la cabeza del ejecutivo francés
durante el próximo quinquenio eso lo
sabré a las 8 de la noche cuando se
publiquen los primeros resultados
preliminares